hey what's up guys my name is the
channel welcome back to
the first episode of another little
series that i'm just starting here right
now
which is going to be called code review
now as you can probably guess from the
title what code review is going to be
all about is me taking a look at some of
your code and then just giving my
thoughts on it now quick disclaimer
i'm not some kind of programming
god to be able to just objectively tell
you that your code is wrong or right
this is
completely going to be just my thoughts
looking at your code trying to help you
out giving suggestions that are
hopefully going to be helpful to you and
the rest of the community
that's all this is about don't take this
as some kind of
absolute guide or anything but hopefully
it's going to both help the community
and show
some common mistakes maybe or things
that just shouldn't really be
done but then also just be a general
good time for us to hang out
and look at some code together so if
you're new to the series which of course
you are because this is the first
episode you can email me at
cherno review gmail.com the email
address will be in the description below
basically just attach your code or some
kind of link to your code as well as the
description of
what your code is what kind of stuff
maybe that you struggle with or that you
want me to specifically review
and then i'll download it set it up i'll
just pick someone arbitrarily
and we'll go with that also feel free to
mention whether or not you want me to
actually
say your name on video maybe you don't
and that's totally fine just let me know
so today we're going to be looking at
this gentleman's code he has written a
small 2d
game engine with no graphical editor it
can render quads render textured chords
render text
play music handle basic stuff move the
quads a bit more
still learning opengl and c plus plus
how to run there's some
instructions here as well as a very
dodgy looking dot ra file
but i'm willing to take that risk for
you guys also
he's 13 years old let's just take a
moment to appreciate that i started
programming when i was 16.
this person here claims that they're 13.
so whatever this code is going to be and
whatever i'm going to say about it it's
gonna be
just i'm trying to be helpful absolutely
no disrespect
absolutely not going to be making fun of
this person's code so let's extract this
raw file and dive into it but first
this video is sponsored by skillshare
for those of you who don't know what
skillshare is skillshare is an amazing
online learning community
where millions of creative and curious
people from all around the world can
come together to learn a new
skill whether you're interested in
creative topics such as photography
videography
illustration that kind of stuff or
you're looking for some help with your
business maybe with marketing or
productivity
skillshare has got you covered they've
really got like this huge library of
very high quality courses that all have
lessons
around five to ten minutes each they're
really bite-sized and they're really
easy to just sit down do a couple in
your spare time
and then continue going about your day
and that's one of my favorite things
about skillshare now coming in at just
under 10
a month for an annual subscription i
think it's a really great price for all
of the skills that you will be learning
but of course you can get a free trial
for a limited amount of time
by clicking my link in the description
below so definitely check it out a
really good place to put some of the
free time that you may have
is into being productive and learning
new skills for sure
thank you again to skillshare for
sponsoring this video okay
so let's take a look at this 2d game
engine so the person here has specified
that we need to go into the script
and then the run debug batch file let's
just take a look at what it actually is
first
we have basically echo off clear screen
here pro blah blah title echo starting
building okay so we're compiling using g
plus plus here in goes a bunch of simple
plus code as well as a bunch of
libraries to
link this seems to be divided up into
various
different directories and the output
files here are the intermediate files
the g
plus plus will actually generate as well
as this final kind of linking stage
where we actually link all of these
object files here with the library files
and all of that and produce an
executable called sandbox.exe now i
think i forgot to mention that
i've never looked at any of this code
before or this project structure before
whatsoever this is my fresh eyes on this
so obviously i might be reading things
slightly wrong or just
keep that in mind and then there's echo
running well like okay cool so i already
have a few things to say about this
this is very unsustainable right as your
engine grows and you have more and more
files
you have to manually keep adding them
here
now you can use g plus plus in slightly
a better way to like just include all of
the cpp files and h files and all of
that stuff and just make things
generally easier
but in general just having a little
batch file that has all of your
files that you're trying to compile and
all of that it's cool that you're
starting that way
because i think a lot of people do start
that way and it's i think that it's
arguably better than starting with like
a full-on ide
and having all of that manage that for
you but my recommendation would be for
sure
to use something like premake or cmake
to just
you know be able to generate project
files for you so that you can easily run
this inside visual studio
and not have to manage the whole build
system yourself
in like a text file because this stuff
is definitely going to get harder to
maintain as you
as the project grows anyway let's try
and run this so apparently we should be
able to just open up command prompt and
then just
run scripts slash i think run debug.bat
now this doesn't work because well i
don't have g plus installed
so let's go ahead and open a min gw
terminal here and hopefully if i
navigate to this directory
and then i will run scripts slash run
debug.bat we should be okay okay so
check this out we have some
pretty interesting music going on and i
think we can even
kind of move this around a little bit
looks a little bit kind of
uh well not very smooth here but 60fps
here we've got some text going on
looks pretty cool i even like the
attention to detail here we have an icon
and all this stuff oh frame rate seems
to have dropped a little bit no we're
okay
pretty cool so we can run the quads and
can't resize the screen or anything like
that
but that is basically what the project
looks like so now let's dive into the
thing that matters
the code so just a few more thoughts
regarding the project structure
now we have an assets file here a bin
file an include file a scripts file
and a source file and of course when i'm
saying file here i mean folder uh with
all of this stuff in here so that's
pretty nice i like to see this kind of
layout usually it's good one thing i
would recommend is maybe
since this is an engine and not just a
game project it would be good to see
some kind of separation of projects so
maybe the engine code should be in a
single
folder and then the actual game code can
be somewhere else and the game can
contain like assets and all of that
whilst the engine code will contain more
of the
kind of engine engine code base so if we
were to open
this folder in visual studio code over
here we'll just be able to easily browse
this repository
it would be nice to see some kind of uh
you know
setup environment here to be able to run
and debug this through vs code if that's
what you've chosen to use and not visual
studio
but that's obviously okay now i'm
apparently in this
file here let's go and uh i guess we'll
start at the top
so so far the source uh directory is
fairly standard i like to see this
vendor folder
again this looks a little bit similar to
the design that i'm using for hazel
which is
fantastic because it's cool to see this
kind of
structure you know with like a vendor
folder with all the third-party stuff
coming from someone who's 13. like
that's
really cool to see so i'm glad to see
that hopefully what i'm doing here on
youtube is also
helping out people with this because
this looks pretty good i would never
have guessed
this was someone who was 13. my code at
that age was well
non-existent but my code in my first
couple years of programming was
nowhere near this organized so that's
already really really cool
okay so we've got sandbox we've got
tools again this this this
stuff to me like sandbox obviously seems
like it should be in a separate project
now this person doesn't really have
projects
uh i mean they are just compiling
everything with g plus plus which is
fine they could still compile this into
like a
you know the engine code into like a
library file to a static library file
then link it to
an exe file and all of that stuff but
you know we're not going to get into
that that's not that important
especially not at this stage in their
programming career
okay so uh basically the the i guess the
main
function is over here let me just make
this slightly bigger we start by just
playing the music which is cool
um then we also set the icon on display
manager now i'm noticing that these
these kind of variables here these
instances of classes i presume
are coming out of nowhere right like
they're obviously
global and you can see them up here
actually in the sandbox.cpp file
they're not even like static global
meaning they're confined to this
translation unit to the cpp file
they're actually just full on global not
a great design
uh in this case i mean honestly like it
doesn't really matter too much
but what i would have liked to have seen
is this display manager
you know there's probably no reason for
it to actually be global like it's not
even used in this kind of stuff this is
also slightly dodgy
what i probably would do is just cut
this code out and just put it over here
into main
this is already a lot better because for
one you'll be calling the destructor
as you exit over here and not sometime
in static destruction
but also this stuff is just kind of
bound to the scope and it won't leak out
into the rest of your entire
project in that kind of global space but
yeah everything else is okay
setting up some icon stuff setting a
resizable yeah this looks pretty pretty
standard to me we've got this kind of
while loop here which is the uh
game loop here or the application loop
looks pretty fine i i would just say
that
this kind of stuff definitely shouldn't
be in your main file
i would make an application class and
have maybe a function called run
which contains this actual game loop
more of like an organizational thing not
really going to impact the like
performance or the general like
way this application runs but it's
something that's very useful to do just
to keep your code more organized
so display manager is pretty much the
first thing that gets created let's take
a look at the display manager class i'm
going to try and be fairly brief here
just because obviously
this this is quite large and uh
i could definitely sit here forever but
i'm going to try and be kind of brief
so we have um we have the display
manager class
which uh takes in a width and height and
a title
so immediately looking at this i would
give a couple suggestions first of all
try not to use unsigned int it's a
little bit outdated
use something like uint32t what this is
is a it's kind of a more modern we'll
say unsigned in type
the big thing that it actually has is a
size you know there's no
there's never a dispute about how big
this integer is
we know that it's an unsigned int is
fairly arbitrary we don't know what the
size is 32
bits is actually written here we know
this is a four bit unsigned integer
as an added bonus it's less characters
than unsigned int so it would actually
make everything else look
a little bit cleaner so i always try and
use um 32 underscore t
for my unsigned int types now std string
title
with this no point taking it in by value
like this
put a little const reference here
because if you don't what you're doing
is actually copying the entire string
into the display manager constructor
this is this is bad i mean
it doesn't necessarily have to be bad
depending on the size of your title
string and all that
but essentially by by changing this to a
const reference you're doing one less
copy potentially i mean you'll still
need to copy it eventually into win
title
but you're not copying it first into the
constructor and then again into when
title copying strings is not that great
because every time you copy a string the
new string has to heap allocate memory
for it to be able to be stored and again
this is subject to like things like
small string optimization but for the
most part
we want to avoid that pretty much any
time you take in a string or any class
that is like larger than let's just say
eight bytes
for the most case you want to just make
it a const reference
uh you know unsigned in as i said to
un-32t
everything else looks pretty good now
personally this is
a very minor thing but personally i like
to actually store this kind of private
stuff
at the bottom of the file now the reason
i like doing this and i actually used to
do it the other way around
but the reason i like doing it like this
is because when someone is looking at
this header file
for the most case right usually they
want to be able to see
what they can do with this class right
they don't really care about the
implementation details which is like you
know
all of this stuff i don't care that it
has some private functions that i'm not
even going to be able to call
right for the most case they just well
for the most frequent case i should say
uh in most cases and that's the right
that's the right phrase i was looking
for
they just want to see what is up and
what they can do with this class and by
putting the public stuff first you're
just kind of
keeping everything a bit more organized
and making it so that you can actually
have that stuff here
we have this usenvidia.h little file
here basically what this does is
tries to force uh dedicated graphics if
you're on a laptop that has integrated
graphics
this is this is fine i guess uh this is
a little bit of a consequence of using
opengl for rendering and not something
like vulcan
which actually lets you programmatically
pick what physical gpu you want to use
and that way you'd
usually pick something dedicated uh
instead of like an integrated card for
something like a game engine so that's
what this is doing that's totally fine
it's in a header file which i assume
gets included into some kind of
translation unit later on
um text shader just stumbled upon this
file accidentally
this is like my first thought on looking
at this is why is everything in the
header file this stuff should be
implemented in a cpp file
as you're developing this file any kind
of change to this code is going to force
everything to be recompiled it includes
this header file
it's a lot better to have that in the
cpp file um
this stuff seems pretty good i tend to
not really use exceptions
just as a stylistic thing in most of my
code but it's totally fine to use them
in most cases um yeah just creating
opengl shader stuff i'd probably
separate this stuff into like a cpp file
as i mentioned
um but everything else i think looks
pretty good pretty standard
uniform setting going on here check
compile errors
for our shader that looks pretty good as
well
uh text rendering stuff
um yeah this stuff is this stuff seems
pretty good
uh again i stuff whenever i see
um scd map i i tend to usually use an
unordered map the reason is an arnold
map is a hash map
it just tends to in most cases be faster
than a map
for looking up things but it definitely
depends on the size and certain other
things so i'm not gonna
just you know blindly give that advice
but i usually use arnold map and i think
that
for the most part that should be the
first thing you choose
um okay sound manager stuff renderer
stuff
okay this is interesting so we have a
vector of float pointer which
are our vertices okay uh let's take a
look at render or cpp because i'm really
interested to see why we have a
vector of pointers so it looks like we
have
um in the renderer add we can add a quad
i don't know what a quad is it'd be nice
to let's just
uh what's the right i think that's it
quads
um okay so what this is is we're
creating a bunch of vertices here on the
stack and indices
then we're copying them onto the gpu
here as an
array buffer and an element array buffer
so we have our vertex buffer and our
index buffer
and that seems that that seems like
that's all we do here
um this gl core macro which i'm assuming
i'm not sure if i can go to it
not really uh i'm assuming this gl call
thing let's just
try and search for it here it is
debugger yeah so
this is kind of like an old way of
checking errors in opengl you don't
really need to do anything like this
anymore if i open up hazel
and i try and just go to to be honest i
don't even know where this is probably
in like gl context maybe
i have no idea where my own code is i
think opengl render api you can see
we've actually got a callback for error
messages now
so gl debug message callback is
something you can use as of like
opengl maybe 4.3 just off the top of my
head
and if you enable gl debug output and gl
debug output synchronous
then you don't actually have to wrap
every gl call in that kind of gl error
check
because anytime you get an error it will
just simply
call this callback and you can even put
a breakpoint in here and see whenever
it's called and then use that as long as
you've got synchronous enabled so it's
not asynchronous
you'll be able to look at the call stack
and see exactly where it's coming from
so
basically gives you the same uh the same
features as
what this does except you know with the
assertion for the breakpoint and all
that stuff
but without having to wrap everything in
this macro so it just makes life a
little bit easier and i would recommend
that you
use something like that um okay so we
we take in a quad we push it back uh and
then what we do here this is very
interesting
so into the into the m vertices vector
we're actually getting the vertices from
the quad so let me first of all see
how that what that's even doing um
[Music]
so where are the vertices from here
am i misunderstanding something so quad
dot vertices
vertices i can't see vertices
so that's a bit odd quad dot vertices
where is this this thing anyway it looks
like
oh it's no it's not here
i've actually found another quad class
here so maybe this is what it is but
anyway this is a vector
of vertices here and i guess this is
what's being pushed back into
here now this is already uh
very dodgy i'm not even sure how this is
working exactly because
this is a temporary object right so what
we're doing here is we're copying a quad
over here which
first of all isn't ideal because the
quad contains a vector
and so we're actually copying all of
this data every time we enter this
function
which means that well that's not great
for performance because vectors for
example will dynamically allocate memory
in most cases
as well as will like potentially other
stuff here so it's a pretty heavy copy
but on top of that
um this object is obviously temporary
it's going to cease to exist at the end
of this function and yet we're actually
getting
the pointer to this vertices vector
contained within this quad instance
that later gets destroyed and putting it
into our member function so in other
words after this function
m vertices is going to contain a float
pointer to
memory that's been deleted so that's
already like a bug
um this stuff uh
okay so this shouldn't really work
either i'm fairly sure because at i
think returns a constant
reference potentially which means that
how we're assigning to a constant
reference
not sure how that compiled unless i'm
just looking at the wrong thing
um yeah but this stuff definitely
shouldn't be happening uh if you want to
actually push indices back you should
allocate your own memory and copy that
instead of relying on this pointer
because that's that that memory is
likely to get deleted
um yeah that's that's very likely to
cause a bug if it's not
if it even works now which i doubt it
okay gl call this stuff
um again gel call can get removed
everything else is probably okay
this is just preparing some opengl stuff
for rendering which is totally fine
and then we have uh the actual render
function
which just enables the shader here sets
the view matrix
calculates the model v projection matrix
binds the vertex array and then
does the draw call now this again not
being called at the moment so i assume
half of this is broken maybe this
is why but uh this doesn't do anything
but we will be setting the uniform here
into the shader
okay so that's the renderer seems pretty
fine i think to me uh let's try and go
back to our files here what else should
we look at
um i'm trying to just uh figure out what
even to look at because obviously we
could be here for hours
uh okay the text renderer itself so this
is um interesting we're drawing a string
here again you know
try and use const references for this
kind of stuff then we're doing a con
iterator here we're iterating through
all the characters i did
see um free type being used earlier
which is great
so we're actually able to um you know
when we initialize the text renderer
it's going to uh fetch certain
characters i assume from the aerial font
here
and then we can actually use uh
opengl here and in this case um we're
actually going through 128 different
characters and then retrieving them from
free type the actual pixel data and then
storing them
using opengl like into a texture
essentially now this again is going to
create 128 different textures
uh it's a lot better to use something
called a texture atlas or a sprite sheet
to just store all of these characters
in one texture so instead of having to
generate 128 different textures and then
having to rebind them all the time you
just have one
kind of sprite sheet which contains all
the characters that you need right
there now obviously that's something a
little bit more advanced a little bit
harder to set up
especially for someone who's 13 let's be
real but uh definitely something that i
would do
because having 128 different textures
for your characters aren't great
also um you are going through all of the
characters here
right so c is being used here we're
literally going through all the
characters that this font contains
almost
so that's also not really necessary what
you can do is just do this on the fly so
whenever you are going through text
that um you know requires a certain
character you can check to see if that
character exists and if it if it doesn't
exist yet because it's the first time
you've used like the letter a
at that point in time you can actually
retrieve it from free type instead of
having to like
create 128 different textures up front
without even potentially needing half of
them
so that's also something i would do but
other than that you know this is pretty
standard just creating a quad basically
so that we can actually you know with
all the font matrix and all that so that
we can actually draw
each character here as a quad and then
just drawing it over here
pretty sanded um and then advancing x so
that we can draw like sentences and
stuff like that
pretty standard text rendering using
free type
cool that's really impressive uh you
know i feel
i remember one of the like when i did
text rendering for the first time i
it probably took me a month if not more
to figure it out
and i was like 20 i think
ish so text rendering definitely isn't
that easy and it's definitely the most
impressive thing
in this engine um you know rendering
quads is not that hard i think
again it's hard for me to picture what
it's like for a 13 year old but
i would think that that's kind of like
not too difficult but i'm definitely
impressed by all of this text rendering
stuff
this looks this looks really good and to
be honest like looking through this code
like yeah you know sure there's some you
know stuff here that probably belongs in
like the engine state and like the
renderer
not necessarily the text renderer
specifically and you know there's this
you know creating 120 different textures
not great either
but you know for the most part it
definitely
very like tidy code very impressive and
like
yeah i honestly this code i would not be
surprised to see this kind of code
laid out in this way you know from
someone
on my team at ea or something like that
back when i used to work there and
that's not to say that ea code is bad
it's just that this person's code is
pretty good okay uh
there's some very physics stuff here
which you know i mean it's just a vector
2 class
and i think textured quad is also
something really interesting
now one thing i do want to mention is
that um one thing i've noticed here is
that uh the quads that we're creating
here they're basically different every
time
so we create a chord with an x y width
and height right which is what's going
on over here
uh and then every time we need a quad at
a different position we create a new
quad and we create a new vertex buffer
and you know set up all the attributes
and do all of that stuff and this is a
textured chord so we also um you know do
all of this stuff for it you don't
really need to do this what you can do
instead is
basically what we do inside hazel and if
we look at
the 2d renderer we just have a quad that
we create once
that's what's happening here we have a
bunch of coordinates actually this is
this is for the batch renderer
but what we do is we basically create a
single quad that is a one by one
unit quad and then with that quad in
mind we upload it like to the gpu and
create a vertex buffer out of it as
usual
but then if we want to render a
different size
quad at a different position and if we
let's say we weren't using a batch
renderer we could just simply use a
transformation matrix so like a scale
rotation translation matrix to just
manipulate
this one quad so you can draw the same
chord many times but then set a uniform
mat four
to be a different transform matrix and
that way you can get any kind of quad
you want with just these vertices and
you can create them once
and you never ever have to create
another quad vertex buffer again
ever so it's really really useful um and
that of that
that's basically how i would probably
write a little quad renderer if i was
not trying to bash them all together or
do anything like that
so definitely something to consider
because you don't really need to have a
textured quad class
you can just have a function inside your
renderer called like submit quad kind of
like what you're doing here with the add
function
but then what that can do is just simply
create a matrix
based out of what the translation
rotation and scale
that the person wants the quad to be
rendered at or the core league i should
say
wants um the quad to be rendered at
on your screen and then that's really
all you need to do then you can just do
a draw call
um or push it back into some kind of uh
queue here or a list
with that matrix and then do a draw call
with that matrix being set as a uniform
and that's kind of
it hopefully that makes sense uh
everything else
um i think that's about it i think we've
gone through pretty much
everything i would definitely clean up
that second quad file i don't know why i
found two there's looks like there's one
in source
um no that is a cpp file i'm really
curious why i found
two different ones that's kind of weird
isn't it because i
definitely go i definitely didn't open
this project twice not sure anyway
hopefully you guys enjoyed this little
code review as
i i mean i i there's no huge problems
here
uh from the code that i've been looking
at this could easily be like a
20 year old 25 year old university
student's code like this is this is
great
and if you really are 13 then amazing
work and if you really did write it
yourself
um then i'm definitely very impressed uh
i think you've got a lot of potential
obviously and
you know just some minor c plus plus
issues like path part
like passing things by const reference
and using you and 32 t instead of
unsigned int and
you know just some standard stuff that i
see all the time as well with you know
maybe not really quite understanding how
pointers work and how if you really want
to take ownership of memory
you may have to copy it and you know all
of that stuff like what we saw with the
whole vector of float pointers and then
just simply
setting that to be the data of some
other quads vector that may be deleted
later on
that apart from that kind of stuff yeah
looks absolutely great
particularly impressed with the whole
text rendering situation that's really
cool and if you figure that kind of
stuff out on your own as well then
like absolutely well done if you have
some code that you want me to look at
then check the email address in the
description below it's
channelreview gmail.com and i'm looking
forward to reviewing a lot more code in
the future
let me know what you thought this is the
first episode if you just don't like the
format of it or if you did like the
format of it or
if you want me to focus on some other
stuff definitely leave a comment below i
am
trying to get as much feedback as
possible since we've just started the
series
and i hope that it will be something
that we can enjoy doing a lot more of in
the future
don't forget to hit the like button if
you did enjoy this video and don't
forget to check out skillshare
using the link in description below
thank you all for watching i will see
you later goodbye
[Music]